yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
which hopefully is live as usual it's
kind of tricky to figure out if I'm
really live I hope I am all kind of
messages indicate that i am live so give
me a quick um yeah quick message in the
chat would be great to tell me if this
broadcast is actually on yeah okay we're
going to do some blitz games again and
I'm really really really hoping and
playing better then last week when I got
ya when i got my mask it quite a bit so
let's see i open to do better what i'm
actually going to do and this is a
slight changes i'm going to answer
questions but we'll do that mostly in
between the games because i really don't
want to lose all the capes like last
week want to try to do a little bit
better okay i'm going to start a
five-minute game and let's see plank
Adele mo yeah my rating is pretty decent
24 33 I am lost more than 100 points
last week but I got that all back in
them in the in the in the week in
between someone writes no sound I don't
know on my end it looks so it looks ok
hmm anybody else got some sound issues
somebody says sound is good ok yeah we
have a green felt here playing the
Bishop f4 line this is a line that I'm
currently studying not really completed
my studies but this is what I'm probably
going to play against the gruene thought
also in we had more important games Len
then
that's just just this blitz game okay
he's going for Bishop chief form yeah
maybe here I'm not sure from bishop f
three years a big problem he is doing
that giving me the double porn but at
least I've got the two bishops black
structures of course pretty solid but
what is he doing with the b7 porn it's
not clear to me what the best movers
yeah I'm going to watch the chat and if
there are questions try to remember them
to address after the game okay so it's
taking their I can't take be seven and I
really don't see why I shouldn't okay
it's got maybe counter play with nine th
five and so on maybe just take with the
bishop that's a simple solution and
cannot be that bad really oh that's a
surprising huh do I go to d3r to eat um
hard to determine let's try to be quick
here
t-shirt I it's just water it's not a tee
shirt that I'm wearing it's getting
warmer though it was a nice day today
okay it's hard to do without castling
yeah okay I wonder probably rook the one
as c5 is going to happen at some point
or a five in both cases the rookies is
fine on d1 huh but I wonder I get in 94
next move there should be quite nice I
know this is not the regular timeslot we
had to have something out of the
ordinary on the ISS each other I'm
yesterday and so we switch to tuesday we
will continue with the regular Monday
time slot next week I don't know if
which had technical issues but there was
another as you see event yesterday that
we did not want to collide with yeah
this is a nice position here right this
is my I'm able to chat a little bit the
sea porn is weak and and don't know what
he should do if you go see if I'm ever
see if I'm taking and wrong I'm just
quicker here a lot quicker I'm I rooks I
in the game and his rooks are not and
possibly i can play f1 in the future
blocking a five entirely that's not a
very comfortable position
online a lower ratings are not
comparable to offline hitter ratings no
of course there's some kind of relation
but it's not them yeah it's not like one
to one or it's um it's not so not so
easy yeah greetings back to Vienna yeah
that looks nice I mean I just took it on
c5 if he takes on c5 and winning winning
a piece ultimately and hmm if he goes
rook c8 I have 94 and maybe it's getting
this pawn back somehow but at the moment
I don't see how exactly I like to move
that you don't want to play if I take
with the Queen for before yeah okay i'm
going to play before here cementing this
porn that's not going to go away anytime
soon okay your age for it it's not
really super dangerous still still a
question of how to play maybe f1
I can play f5 actually try to open up
the the position I let's do that now i
won't play in the Latvian gambit an
opening that is basically losing right
from the start I won't play it is really
that bad it's very very close to just
being completely lost so no way willing
to experiment from time to time but I
don't play totally bonkers openings um
okay Queenie for was my idea just wanted
to to trade you know how do I take
probably it's not mattering very much it
does not matter very much yeah b5 is
hanging I've looked before though I
think for for the doubling yahoo cd1 now
is the threat and Bishop b5 on top of
that it looks difficult yeah he really
got into a bad situation right out of
the opening
no he's out of his out of moose
basically okay I'm going to do here
there is no trick just doubling yeah I
now okay i can take be five then Luke be
eight that's not bad but i also like
this move just for taking on d5 next
it's also a very simple simple way to
win and there's a slight issue that is
absolutely no time Oh came so I'm coming
up with a king now
okay let's say let's pick up some some
other stuff
okay if I take them then he will I mean
it still wins but
I am cared wasn't that wasn't really
good technical play now let's let's do
it differently it's just that it lets
say use the King here and now i'm
running into this was check that was
stupid I mean okay as mentioned it still
wins but it wasn't really great I
offered me a draw and it's kind of silly
it is still winning for wine
yeah oops now that that was still
winning I've been cutting the king of
somewhere I would win with the new
senior position at the end so it wasn't
great technical play but winning the
whole time okay um I don't know if I
really addressed some of the question
there was one question about the game a
variation of the French defence this is
with ninety to ninety six that's a
pretty decent line it's a pretty okay
and can lead to I'm quite uncommon
situations that the white players quite
often wouldn't them I wouldn't know so
much now chess in pop culture and I
don't know there is nothing great I
think maybe you can correct me on that
but it's nothing really great I never
saw that musical chess maybe this is
something i don't know i never saw it
okay playing against cheetah totally
forgot this opening takes Teague's
Quincy to I know if I was in line hmm
maybe castling it's been been ages since
I first since I looked at this opening
line White is some very quick here
obviously with us with his castling and
whole development but I have a nice
bishop on f6 mmm how do you play that
you want to play c5 ok I'm going to do
that and not think about it for too long
it's the sharpest move definitely going
for Queen 85 and trying to to make use
of this bishop so up to up to here CDE
Dean look takes this Bishop is six then
I'm going to take another taking what
did not I did not even think about the
move but of course you can play that I
can take a two but my king position
it was going to be bad okay I still go
there otherwise it doesn't make any
sense maybe he can play nights at seven
but this looks very dangerous okay hmm
yeah I'm not sure about this position
maybe I'm in bad shape but it is it's
it's complicated it's not a very simple
thing to play what's king is not in
great shape as well it's not that in
great shape either I keep making making
that mistake nitey form hmm I
interesting he wants to take only six ok
I can hear the chick here could be one
yeah okay maybe rook c8 getting ready
for four see foul play I'm a pound down
here but this is this is not really a
problem this is so completely this is
just total dynamic dynamics yeah I
Scotty five possibly because of Queen g6
but I don't know how dangerous that is
then I can take on c5
if i go to e5 he has this rookie a
rookie five the check is not giving me
much so I'm going back he can play if
I've but I wanted to go look c5 then
maybe this is complete nonsense Queen g6
checking if I cannot go to f8 hmm ok
yeah it's not ok on on e5 I can play for
Queen g6 check I can't play King g7 it's
not it's not terrible maybe and ok i
have i have some kind of counter play
yeah okay so i go here that was not
intended but it's not so clear now
someone asked me about hot today's st.
Patrick's Day the Irish holiday on day
to celebrate and I actually have a
Guinness I have one I don't wear so for
later if I play well i need to score at
least a little bit um okay look f5 check
is a look at five with some one problem
look at five don't have any tricks
cannot even cover cover this in some way
not good not good at all I don't see a
player will move here this is not what
you want to do really isn't
rook t6 coming off what is this issue
probably a t6 t3 to now that's not
looking any good I look 26 I cannot even
take you to because of Luke f7 hmm
no no tricks no nothing no really you
have to have to yeah it was very
difficult this position I I think that
I'm not really used believing that this
is so great for what but but maybe maybe
it is this problem I don't know very
difficult position very very difficult
position ok let's go for the next game
um the Irish gambit what is the what is
the Irish gambit I did not know I do not
know when I was opening what is the
transvestite opening with the world
white I don't know ok c5 mmm ok let's
try to get further for the ok 96 I
wanted to say i go for the roxy point
but 96 is a very uncommon way to play so
i can go a five now Mel it that's all
very strange if he goes night before i'm
doing this year i know i can take you 5
f well then takes e4 actually ok so this
little trick is not going to work ok I'm
going to play this then there's a
question have I ever played atomic chess
vieira well as a kid who probably want a
once or twice but not but not not a lot
not not a huge practitioner of any
Chesson
very NJ the only thing that that we
played quite a lot as kids was about
house which was always fun and they're
still think this is a decent to do
sometimes for even for kids why not if
you don't overdo it it's it's fun and
you learn some you learn some some good
tactics and creativity why not ok I'm
going to take them and take them arguing
that at the end he will have this
somewhat strange night on a five I came
so i can if he goes be fine i'm just
taking that and what I'm doing is I'm
preparing Bishop out and 94 ok he maybe
wants to play be fat but i can't play b3
really it's some very simple reply yeah
atomic chess is a chasm variant where if
you take something everything around it
is kind of bombed away so um if you go
night 193 and the threat is Knight e5
and winning because it that would bomb
the way the king it's it's it's kind of
weird it's fun about them I'm not quite
sure if this is this a forced win for
white I don't know I think there's
probably some some people who invested
some time to figure that out okay about
this game what I'm trying to do is I'm
really trying to prove that this night
only five is some is missing in blacks
are me if you want to call it like that
if he goes be 5 i'm going to play b3
just keeping it autumn out in the open
do I think that mangoes cards will read
my book I don't think so but would be
nice promotion if he would what set do
that um it's it's also i mean it's
mostly catered towards a different
audience right not exactly for the super
GM okay so let's see
Queen f4 looks like a good idea at five
is a very weakening move hmm also nighty
to chair force a good idea yeah let's do
that keeping an eye on this this night
the same time and then trying to yeah
I'm trying to keep it out of the game
retakes btx he can go rook be eight
maybe but my ideas to play night f 496
that was my point of night to e2
debatable Oh is closing it nah I don't
believe in that much it takes a long
while to get them to get this get this
in the game you have to cover that night
to make my queen mobile again if he goes
to h6 I have rupee 7 ok so and now 96 is
a good move definitely but I would like
to enter with Queen and rook he's got
rookie eight coming yeah I won them to a
g'nite insects or not yeah I guess I
should do that rookie ADA play Bishop f1
so that he cannot grab they're only 6
and maybe he's ok somewhat night the
idea sir is a move Trading's even more
stuff
yeah remarkable he defended that's quite
well yeah okay so he decides to take the
after all I was thinking that after
takes Bishop takes Queen d6 this is
still quite unpleasant and c5 Hanks and
e6 is threatened because of this Bishop
t5 pinning idea so I'm kind of surprised
that he allowed that that looks very
nice for white actually what is he doing
now to prevent the immediate loss now
Bishop d5 we take c5 is threatened ok so
Bishop g5 is still a move right but
maybe not a winning move Bishop d5
Bishop f7 doesn't seem to win at least
not immediately ok let's grab the pawn
if in doubt take the pawn yeah thanks
for the question about them Magnus
garden being interested in my book as I
mentioned I really don't think it would
help him very much but it is some known
that he really does read chess books
it's one of the very few top players who
actually do that most of the top players
they they don't really buy any books I
don't know if this is such a great idea
to don't do that i mean you can always
argue they they analyze their self so
which is true but sometimes I mean
people authors have invested a vast
amount of time on on their books and it
so it can give you some interesting
ideas even if you don't um adopt the the
suggestions one by one even even then it
might make sense to have a look because
there might be related ideas or things
that that can still be useful for you
okay so what am I going to do here I'd
like to check and get the beef up on
maybe I should first of all make sure
that the black rook is not invading and
then I can still play rugae form yeah so
King III okay can give I can put that
here right this is not a bad square for
the bishop one day and I definitely
should start to increase my speed 41
seconds is not good yeah Group A for
work takes before is the simple way to
go and he still does not have much
okay now he's spending quite some time
going to bring the king of King d6 King
define for c5 check possibly he still
cannot really invade or do anything
active here look to f2 possibly okay if
I give this check i'm kind of chair
making my own look look stupid so I'm
going to start with that and take this
pawn here right it's no reason not to
I'm still behind on the clock
g2 is covered nice little detail
I wanted to go to see three actually but
it's okay
what you want to get in rook f7 you gave
a check made coming no pay for very long
time that's good okay so let's see is
there any question that i did not see
can amend without chest tenant become a
good player because of hard training
yeah it's so it's a matter what you call
good that's really the case um with very
little talent I think things are limited
that you that you can do but really
about everybody who is not um who say on
11 any normal person let's say was not
like handicapped in some way they should
be able to get to a 2000 level or
something like that but in some cases
might take very very hard work it simply
people see the board differently if you
want some people they they see things
quicker and understand the kind of inner
workings a lot better yeah in the final
position he has rook takes d5 bishop a
two that's funny yeah okay I only had
eight seconds so this is this can happen
I have requested a new game but did not
did not start yet it's definitely not
possible for every player to become
let's say a grandmaster on IM I don't
think so you need to have some kind of
some kind of hang for the game at least
a little bit so it's not like everybody
can do it I requested a new game but it
did not did not start yet yeah is it is
it time is it time for some fuel I don't
know I have won a couple of games at
least so it wouldn't be totally
undeserved yeah I don't know I get a
game against hematite Brown let's see
okay
yeah what's the rating that everyone can
reach me I'd never put in much thought
about that but a good a good club level
1802 2000 should be possible for for
most people I really think so okay so
let's just castle here and play this I I
keep forgetting this opening variation
people um tend to play that once in a
while have i ever played online drunk
mm-hmm now probably not not what you
really would define as drunk I mean like
him and after two or three beers sure
but that's not what I call drunk mmm how
will you determine who is allowed to
play in this samuel event next Friday
yeah please I'm this some money from icc
Sandra please given information out
about that I'm not sure how the sim you
look who is going to play ok what I can
tell you about this game is that this
guy systematically rectus LightSquared
bishop so after before I'm going to put
a knight on d4 and I'm very happy about
that I can take which is not much better
i also have Bishop g5 coming yeah it is
Friday this Friday so it's the
eighteenth 1989 and the 20th yeah before
with before I'm getting this c3m this
c3m away and then I get deformed this
nice square
how did my chest Korea start Korea
sounds really big yeah never really saw
it as a big career anything but okay um
how did it start I play dumb I learned
the rules of chess very early on really
as a kid um maybe with six seven years
old or so but I never played really I
mean I knew how to play but I never
played and it only it was a little bit
later that I played with my grandfather
quite a bit which was funny because for
some reason he liked to play and we had
lots of fun doing it but it was quite
quite funny that he somehow had the
wrong starting position with knights and
bishops chain changed yeah the Knights
were on c1 and f1 and the bishops on g1
and b1 which was really funny when I got
my first chess book and I learned that
oh wow this is this isn't right you know
we've been playing it all wrong all of
it the whole time and we had to change
it and it was quite funny had some
issues to adjust to that and yeah we
still kept playing but this would change
I sort of helped me a little bit and I
don't know i mean i started to to win
against him and then they started them
something at my school some kind of
scholastic thing where you could could
learn chess from from a stronger player
and and I don't really know how good
this guy was but he was pretty decent
maybe on a 1800 level or so he played
correspondence chess which at the time
was a bit different of course because
back then they actually had to play
themselves and he didn't have any
computers and yeah so um and I started
to take it a bit more serious than and
really started to to to to to get books
and things like that and yeah I
going to chess club pretty pretty
quickly and then started to play on a
more competitive level let's aim it was
really late I only joined the chess club
at age 14 so it proves that even when
you start relatively late them um you
can still get to a pretty pretty okay
level especially if you really invest
lots of time which I definitely did and
but from then it it was aight i gained
points pretty quickly but well really i
invested so much time that is some
pretty much beyond beyond sensible okay
what am I going to do here he was he
will play at four and i'm wondering what
to do about that i mean i can just
ignore it i have the queenside blocked
g5 looks kind of terrible mm I don't
know how to react to have four I mean I
can still simply share allow that I
played Bishop detour so I'm not quite
sure yeah when I started to play chess
are pretty much abandoned everything
else it's just like that I can I can't
help it I mean it's not that I didn't
have any interest in other things at all
but really am the the vast majority of
time was invested for the game Queenie
5pm this is kind of nice because my
bishop looks better than he is but it is
very very little what a half year if
anything at all
fatigue here Bishop t to be sure b.ed
look p8 shop f6 look b1 rook f1 whom
there is nothing at the end of this line
yeah I came now it really it is it is
not much at all if anything maybe here
to cover bishop d2 as a I mean threat as
I has a strong word that at least that
I'm getting to infiltrate a little bit
with my rook it is just equal
disposition probably um hmm okay I did
not expect that move but I can I can he
can just go back there right okay but
here i can actually go to before which
is at least a little bit active looking
at the a4 porn I cannot take what a
shame I go here is going to play Bishop
b5 may I am okay so maybe I can get the
King to e5 and pretend to have the
active King that's a question what what
what do you think about the other buck
variation of the Kings and yes this is
the line that I play from time to time
it's a very safe line that is risking
very little and something that black
players tend to not know so well so it
is a good choice to play
mmm so this is really so easy I'm
getting to d3 right it's probably still
a draw but I wouldn't have allowed that
as as wide that looks looks kind of
strange I'm getting b3m and this is
trouble I think he I think you missed
played that this is doing a home run the
bishop won't be five is simply not
playing at all well this was a draw
really that was it wrong but ok Bishop
Bishop over to e4 maybe this is a
defense no he resigned probably not
anyway ok any questions umm Amer better
than Daniel wrench i think we are quite
evenly rated write something like 24
something yeah carleton place amateur
still plays amateur football yeah maybe
he does I don't know it's a decent
football player heard about that and
there are pictures of course that's a
question if I ever smoked or do smoke
yeah i actually did smoke quite heavily
but I quit um two years ago thankfully
I'm really glad that I stopped that it's
it's really it's a bad habit okay we got
a sloth defensed here against kiri
Annette's Carlo de Moura frequent
opponent and he's got a pretty low
rating I think he's a really good player
um especially in blitz I mean I never
looked at his tournament games but he's
a really good blitz player giving me
trouble all the time I don't have a good
record against him minus two so it's
kind of weird but okay let's take that
okay so we have a sloth kind of
structure where he's giving me very
happy Wow Ronald where he hasn't given
me the bishop pay up um ok the question
is do I want to go for queen bee three
here queen bee 65 this kind of business
mmm i'm not sure i think i'm just going
to complete development and try to make
it difficult for him to get the freeing
moves and
case simply normal moose I don't do much
tactics training unfortunately it's not
I don't really have that much time for
my former owner own chest because of my
chest teaching job and and other things
books and so on so my own chest is kind
of neglected a little bit if if I'd if I
do something there i'm going to and try
to solve very difficult tactics I mean
tactics in terms of calculation
exercises not like animated two or
something just complicated positions
that that are hard to hard to figure out
only move by move basis okay in this in
this position I'm hoping to do something
with the affair with the C file i'm also
looking at this a six pawn this is often
a problem with black has opened up his
Queen side like that they suffer from
those light squared weaknesses
how many bullet games out of 100 I would
win against Nakamura not many he is
really exceptionally good at bullet I
mean really really really really good
hey okay so what am I going to do here
I'm just going to take a plane I'd be
three maybe why do I want to win the win
the pawn here nighty for Bishop f4 EF
takes maybe d5 I don't know 94 Bishop
takes Queen takes Knight f6 Queenie
firefighters better from white so I
should probably just take the pawn this
position is better for white at least a
little bit he still has those weaknesses
yeah I would definitely win less than 10
bullet games against the camera that's
no question absolutely no question if I
really practice hard Buddha chest I'm
not totally terrible but really am no no
hey congrats so good at it um um yeah I
will do the odd budet video I will not
not not not many of them it's simply a
case that I am its I like to play once
in a while but I really have to be in
the mood you had to do that and it's not
that it's not something that would be a
big feature on the channel let's say the
viewer game son would definitely be a
major part of the of the channel I
couldn't do much the last couple of days
because I was busy on the whole weekend
and today I had teaching and so on
yesterday as well so it's some
it's something that is some not that
this not happened the last couple of
days but will be a regular thing of this
channel of course okay so let's see he's
trying to get this play against the pawn
here but II six is hanging was checked
so it's not really a big issue night f5
I can play d5 and Roxy seven is a threat
yeah if you want to improve your
positional play you really have to look
at mini games with with by my good
strategic players players who have a
hang for that and yeah I mean watching
let's say some games of online chess by
decent strategic players can help I mean
I think I'm mostly a strategically
focused player so you might see the odd
interesting moment in my games for
example but of course there's other
other good content also i am also on the
SSC for example if you look at the the
games them or the videos there by many
authors like a games of the week bye bye
Joel Benjamin things like that if you
study those explanations and so on this
is some this is going to be very helpful
okay bye now on two pawns up and I have
this the deep on
yeah I'm going creepy 6cm trying to get
in I mean I wanted to get rid of the pin
and if he takes I think the beep on will
do the do the talking okay he has rookie
one as a final little trick so i can
trade queens if I like or play g3 hmm we
are trading trading Queens so it's very
simple actually so let's just do that
and now maybe g3 in two points and I'm
threatening Roxy 694 coming
okay so how am I going to do that rube
c6 right 94 hook f6
yeah I'm a little bit a little bit low
on time so I need to look at this a
little bit more closely I'm like five
points up four points maybe route 76 or
something to crash through on g6 he's
taking quite some time but I think I've
I can I can still just take here right
yeah and the rooks is six is blundering
stuff but it's what is his threat here
to take and rookie three I can take with
with the rook hair right so I can merge
the airport yeah I'm a bit slow still
here but quite clearly I have a ton of
pawns even Luke c6 azimuth
g5 mate is my idea we can sacrifice the
night there it was kind of unnecessary
that was unnecessary really
I'm playing this kind of in a very
stupid way but it is it is probably so
winning then it does not matter much a
very bad technical play but it wasn't um
it wasn't really a yeah it wasn't
possible to spoil it I tried it but I
didn't didn't do them okay let's see um
do you recommend going gambit for the
club player hmm hmm yeah it is not such
a great gambit if you want to play again
that after a 45 I can recommend the
Evans gambit for example this is a good
um a good gambit or play like this is
fried liver yeah this is not a gambit
but it leads to very dynamic play these
kind of openings are good to study if
you want a more tactical game if you
want a technical game that is really
completely sound and challenging you can
play the scotch the simple Scotch game
which is really the open open game let's
say with D for ED 494 this can get quite
technical and it's interesting to
explore after Bishop c5 on you for you
play Knight be three witches sharp and
Knight f6 you take player 5 the mises
variation ok Impa towable I have a bad
score against the sky 22 games two
losses so and I remember that last week
I had a very nice position against him
that I somehow managed to totally spoil
it was was it the same opening possible
I don't remember don't remember exactly
yeah this is the Yates variation of the
Ray Lopez an interesting line that I'm
quite um
then I quite like for white I mean not
that white is better but it is an
interesting way to avoid the sorry guys
okay at a switch of my my ringtone iam
um it's an interesting way to play if
you want to avoid the main lines and g6
probably yeah nice now um no my male I
have no by Bishop this kind of I should
have taken on f3 first hmm my bishop
doesn't make much sense now can go to e6
actually and knight c6
now that's not good okay 96 is another
huge problem maybe I can go to e6 f3b
should be six not a very impress I
hoping plane okay did not take on these
6mm my RK yes at five that's it's clear
hmm it's not a good position what can
you do I try to not to fall hopelessly
behind on the clock at least f5 g takes
it takes bishop d 5 mm it's not good
it's not good at all
it just rots and it's just a bad bad
kind of piece of place material and he
just improves step by step maybe he now
sufficient to d7 not that this is great
or anything but maybe at five I know can
go back to the seven
yeah Bishop d7 is not a brilliant
looking move but maybe still right is
six maybe for some trades but I'm still
worse the pawn on d6 is just weak it
really is one day hmm q oh I write half
I should 95 b5 I just blundered into 95
okay did not pay attention there okay ah
might be five
yeah I'm kind of still standing but not
very firmly it's just just not very good
nite nite back here to e6 to trade some
stuff or maybe here checking you for
maybe try to trade d4 against this
useless bishop huh yeah it's not much
fun
now you can go queen d4 and simply grab
the pawn yeah that's a pretty it was a
pretty good game my white I mean I
didn't play very challenging stuff just
played badly but it looks like he is not
even doing that this is always wrecking
my nerves and if they have very simple
winds like night and queen d 4 and then
they play something fancy but probably
it is it's just as good okay I don't
don't get it what is the point look
everyone maybe it's too it's also
winning okay we'll go with a little sea
ok you can still win d 6 but this is now
under and the less favorable
circumstances then then earlier still
favorable but it was it was even worse
earlier ok so
a six is hanging still still a big
problem the only little hope that I have
is that this Bishop only one at the
moment looks kind of stupid but it is a
relatively small hope as as mentioned
the other opus that is maybe maybe is
playing some some more we had moved but
it is some nothing you can base your
play upon strange play by the opponent
and still much worse yeah but let's see
how what he comes up with to win the
game okay oh that's neat that's a neat
tactic I didn't didn't see that one at
all did I have something to avoid it I
don't know
jam I can probably just resign this at
three points right but there's a there's
an important rule and Blitzen bullet
chest you never resign when you still
have a light and I'm trying to following
that rule okay attique here is going to
play h6 soft go back it's just totally
lost I know any kind of trickery that I
can go for probably not some kind of
self made in the game um yeah
Jim as mentioned this is not replaying
it too well but my position is so bad I
can take with the rook okay so that was
nice one
some kind of self-made in them gfy it's
not a maid unfortunately can I somehow
Knight f3 some kind of meat probably not
right
and the likelihood is very low okay I'm
go inside now okay I did not want to
want to give up there somehow yeah that
was a loss he played really really well
um some some questions let's say let's
see is there a way to play the petrol of
Defense aggressively now the Petrov is
not by nature very passive opening
actually it's just symmetrical um
difficult it's it's difficult the Petrov
is for the very very solid guys so no
habit right leeches dork mmm yeah I
friend pointed me to the server but I
just I just played a couple of games
it's really i mean there's little point
in playing that if you play on the SSC
really um just just how it is you have
them the best opposition on the ISS see
you get the most interesting games um
yeah would i buy a book by only gas
probably not don't want to finance the
guy can't help it I haven't played him a
lot recently yeah if you some questions
are good i'm going to do some some
questions what youtube channel do you
watch on a regular basis um okay I do
watch in terms of chess channels I do
watch um I can actually open this beer
right watch that's kind of tricky I to
watch the st. Louis chess club of course
yeah Cyril one especially it's always
entertaining and sometimes interesting
not sometimes interesting sounds weird
right it depends a bit he sometimes does
kids classes I mean I don't watch there
but if he does something some general
kind of thing I'm going to watch that I
also watched John baton amuse channel
sometimes for for some bullet for
example bullet bullet over breakfast
it's my yep yeah but it needs it needs a
moment of course to be properly
improperly drinking condition um yeah
what-what also um I do i do watch
kingscrusher once in a while as you may
know is a friend of mine and he wondered
sometimes watches he does this one hour
shows where he does classic games this
is something that I sometimes watch for
entertainment those old games I mean I
kind of know them but it's um it's still
nice to to look at once in a while like
old fishing games or something um
there's something else yeah chest 24 of
course I do watch chest 24 one in a
while they have they have some German
videos on which i watch um Joe those
that's it that's it the icc channel is
also of course there but the videos that
i normally get from from the from from
the website or from from the from the
icc interface let's say where they
announced the videos they sometimes are
on the youtube channel as well but i
don't need to go there yeah the
simulator and i'm going to have the
Guinness now
it was good okay guys um what was my
rating after one year of chessmen it's
hard to tell because while I started
outside of the chess club after I had to
join the Chess Club my first rating was
about 1800 after one year yeah that's a
question do I read the comments on my
youtube videos yes I actually do read
all the comments but it's difficult to
to answer I mean I sometimes answer
simply um like I'm sitting there I see
it and I say okay i can write this in
that I am I only am answer the odd
comment I don't answer all of them it's
simply not doable sometimes I delete
comments if they are very a spam spam
like let's say and I don't really think
they they make much sense so then I
delete them but if you welcome to to
post questions you can also always
directly message me on youtube and I'm
going to answer absolutely yeah okay i
hope you enjoyed the little show enjoy
send patrick's day whether you're in
Ireland or not it's always some good to
find some reason to relax with some
friends or yeah like me having having
this one okay I hope you enjoyed the
show I'll be back on Friday for the
Samuel and um um next week on Monday for
the regular show thanks guys bye